Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and we just got
another full trailer for guardians of the
galaxy.
We got a nice full on look at Ronan The Accuser
and the Collector.
So for my bonus Marvel video this week I’m
just going to break down the new footage and
some of my favorite things.
Let’s just start with the coolest top 5
things.
Number 5 - The music.
This trailer added Spirit in the Sky and kept
the same Hooked on a Feeling from the last
trailer.
It ties into Peter Quill’s anachronistic
taste in music.
He listens to classic rock and flies a space
ship.
That as well as all of them being a bunch
of well meaning dirtbags sets this really
funny tone for the movie.
The Avengers was funny, but Guardians is going
to turn the knob to 11.
It’s totally ridiculous and I can’t wait
to see it.
Number 4 - Groot Speaks
Vin Diesel estimated that he said “I Am
Groot” at least a thousand times in the
recording booth.
He has a language, but only Rocket Raccoon
can understand him.
It’s a lot like Han Solo and Chewbacca.
A really furry short Han Solo and a really
tall fibrous Chewbacca.
We also got to see some of his powers.
He does have some unique abilities including
the ability to regrow himself from a single
piece of his skin.
Like a spore.
He regenerates, because his skin and limbs
get chipped off all the time.
That flower he handed to the girl too probably
grew off of him.
He also popped some spikes like Wolverine
pops his claws.
I’m really looking forward to watching him
get blown up and then regrow himself.
Number 3 - We got to hear Glenn Close
She is playing Nova Prime, the leader of the
Nova Corps.
Think of her as like a giant step up from
Cobie Smulders in Winter Soldier.
She’s like the Nick Fury of the Galactic
version of SHIELD.
They’re really pushing John C. Reilly as
the face of the Corps in all the trailers,
so I’m guessing he’ll be spending way
more time with the Guardians than Glenn Close.
But a lot of people are wondering if there
will be any Nova as in Nova the superhero,
easter eggs.
He’s not supposed to be in the movie, but
fingers crossed they include a reference or
two.
Number 2 - A full on Shot of The Collector
It’s implied that he’s working for or
working with Thanos in the movie.
Obviously because Thanos is such a huge deal
he’s probably not going to be in any of
these early trailers.
But supposedly Marvel cast him and he’s
part of the story.
Those are all just rumors, so take that with
a grain of salt.
The Collector will be the most visible antagonist.
He’s just trying to Collect all the different
infinity gems.
He’s already got a couple of them.
and my number 1 moment - Ronan The Accuser
I’m totally digging Ronan’s look.
We also got a look at the Accusser Corps.
Which is his army of Kree soldiers which serves
justice in their territory of the Galaxy.
They’re like an opposing but equal force
to the Nova Corps.
Lots of different galactic organizations out
there.
But this movie will set the stage to go way
beyond the small SHIELD earth-based stuff
we’ve been seeing since the First Avengers
movie.
Ronan for the most part is an antagonist to
the Guardians, but in the comics he has worked
with the Guardians and the Avengers.
So he’s not crazy like the Collector.
It’s more of like a Darth Vader - Emperor
Situation.
Nebula, Karen Gillan’s character is a full
on villain though.
And I’m so excited to see her.
She’ll also be working for the collector
with Ronan.
They haven’t released any details about
how this movie will tie in with Avengers 2,
which is the next movie after this.
Other than the macguffin of the infinity gems.
Avengers 3 is really when those become a big
part of the story.
So I’m not expecting too many Avengers shout
outs in the movie.
But we might get another Avengers post credits
scene.
Or even an Ant Man teaser, since that’s
the next movie after Avengers 2.
But now it’s your turn, let me know what
your favorite new thing was.
Groot talking or seeing the Acusser Corps?
This tuesday I’ll be doing a bonus Star
Wars video, so be sure to subscribe to get
it.
I’ll also do a Marvel Q&A if you guys want
me to.
Just let me know.
And be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Right now click here to learn all about the
marvel tv shows coming this fall including
the netflix shows and Click here for my Star
Wars Episode 7 Cast breakdown.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight!